tous attendent un an mais à peu près
tout territoire télé réalité
je crois qu'avec jennifer lopez s'était
pas ouf il a eu toutes les stars c'était
spécial avec jenifer ou quoi ce que ben
nikos annonce qu'il faut que je prenne
l'avion le lendemain d'ailleurs j'ai eu
la chance de faire le dernier vol du
concorde et là j'arrive en dit non
qu'est ce que tu portes elle n'aime pas
donc il faut changer de vêtements là
mais qu'on me ramène des vagues ensuite
on dit tu vas monter sur scène elle va
arriver tu ne la regarde pas tu regardes
au dessus de son épaule va être pris
profil et tu récites contexte elle va te
répondre mais non ces matches là non non
non c'est nagui ça c'est hallucinant
quand même voilà donc si on devait
passer plus de temps ensemble et ça a
été une grosse complicité du coup oui et
non c'est même pas le droit tu vois le
mec me dit son manager m'a dit si elle
tombera ce tumulte à pau bas mais je
fais comment donc auquel viennent me
fais la mise donc je je tente quelque
chose
[Musique]
qui
c'est qu'est ce qui se passe dans le bas
j'ai été tenté et nous a trompés temps
atteint j'ai trompé je me suis vengé
parce que ce que tout le monde sait
maintenant ce que j'ai dit plusieurs
fois puis à maintes reprises ouais c'est
qu'un jour avant l'émission je m'étais
déguisé en blonde avec des lentilles
bleues et je suis parti de griller dans
une discothèque est en panne action
concurrence et c'est déjà arrivé
déterminé pas du coup brandon apprend
que tu l'a trompée et pète les plombs
sous le choc des images brandon enfreint
toutes les règles de l'émission et ses
chats cour rejoignent palmetto le site
des femmes hors de lui brandon c'est
armé d'un bâton et devient totalement
incontrôlable on note un réseau
l'expérience j'entends ma femme avec un
bâton il faut taper tout le monde c'est
oui à ça tu as marqué et et la suite
c'est quoi vous vous séparez totalement
l'émission s'arrête en fait la prod a dû
intervenir ouais on voulait tous se
barrer en fait mais moi j'étais ultra
jalouse amoureuse enfin malheureuse
aussi et lui la pète un cap ce qu'il se
rendait pas compte de l'amour qu'il
avait pour moi cette époque là quand tu
m'avais embrassades autres mecs ça y est
la son cerveau la vrille et voilà
j'étais complètement d'escaladé capable
de vous dire écouter une émission n'a
plus de courir demain pour n'était pas
dans la réalité quand même quand on est
parti faire ses missions aujourd'hui tu
me dis va la faire c'est dire et non
c'était quoi ton métier avant
d'institutions j'étais dans quad à
l'époque j'étais 5 et 2 étoiles à
chercher des yeux
tous à temps mais on est à peu près tout
territoire télé réalité c'est qu'on est
beau c 'est pas à franchir quelques
appartements voilà
sept les choses ensemble clavier ouais
mais oui bien qu'à ma vie plus heureuse
maintenant que j'ai pris du poids parce
qu'on me regarde plus comme un comme un
steak ou très belle robe noire comme une
femme normale et je suis bien et le fait
de travailler ça me donne envie de
revivre depuis
grégory est un garçon simple il vit
grâce à des chantiers et des petits
boulots il va échanger sa vie modeste
contre une vie trépidante de multi
mignonne à jour fortier secrétaire
particulier désormais riche il doit
apprendre les codes de son nouveau monde
avant que greg le millionnaire ne
rencontrent ces vingt prétendants
parmi nous ne doit y avoir certainement
des retours
trouvera-t-il celle qui l'aimera pour
lui et non pour ses millions
[Musique]
c'est là que dans les trois dernières
en quatrième cinquième et a eu de ce
dîner mythique on s'en souvient a tous
bien sûr ou ou greg était dur mais de
partout
quand même
éléments d'appréciation à mr souhaite
enfin chien
je suis sûr partout je suis dur par tous
là
c'est durant sept jours comme tous les
sens du terme
d'émetteur vacances dans cette maison et
ça appartenait en fait à arreau mes amis
d'un ex voilà donc tu arrives dans la
maison capreau déloyale très bien
qu'elle n'appartient pas à gré avec
l'année et qui a des portes qui sont
fermés à québec des cadenas comme quoi
tu vas dans nos locations est indiqué
dans le jeu bah j'ai en fait on m'avait
déjà prévenu à la veille du départ ledy
j'étais dans la listing en fait le
listing en fait des candidates ouais et
on m'avait dit que du coup c'est à ibiza
soyez pas trop un oui est en fait
effectivement donc on est parti à ibiza
et donc j'ai compris tout de suite que
et en plus je le connais c'est grave
mais non en fait avant il n'était gogo
dance emmerdes n'était pas ma 6ème tous
danser alors c'est un tel succès
qu'après tu as ton émission marjolaine
et les millionnaires là en revanche tu
couches non sur les dix sièges j'en ai
choisi qu'un oui mais toi
que maintenant tu vend de l'immobilier
mais de l'immobilier de luxe un cécité
veut acheter un truc à 300000 battus
voire plaza ac et non là c'est des trucs
à 10,15 millions d'euros on a vu à dubaï
dans tout tu vente arrivé tout ça c'est
des mobiles de luxe et donc dès 13h
restée mariée non on s'est séparés ya
six ans en mer il ya six ans et
libertaire qui cherche l'amour je
cherche pas spécialement l'amour tu
cherches l'argent du chercheur et non en
fait je vais accepter l'idée de vie
seule théorie va le dire mais tout le
monde dit ça va être dit voilà le gars
le garçon de tes rêves et ressemblerait
à qui ce serait quoi qu'elle en dise et
moi ouais j'ai 41 ans dans les vallons
usagers toi
physiquement comment fin physiquement
faut qu'ils soient pas trop gros pas
trop gros blond et musclé pas facilement
musclé parce que j'ai remarqué que les
gens qui aiment ce qu'ils font
[Applaudissements]
non mais c'est pas mignon
[Musique]
ça commente à capter complètement par
hasard en fait à l'époque je dansais
souvent dans des émissions de télé ouais
et j'ai un pote danseurs qui me branche
pour un casting j'arrive dans le casting
il a joué avec un journaliste en face de
moi qui me pose pendant une demi heure
des questions et je me dis bon c'est
forcément pour une pour une émission de
télé réalité mais je sais pas du tout
pourquoi j'y allais dans quoi je
m'engageais à l'émission démarre faut
quand même se rappeler que c'est des
scores cédé 6 millions et surtout faire
une époque louis qui devient une énorme
star et la panique a tf1 on découvre un
que tu as un casier judiciaire et deux
que tu as tourné des films un petit peu
érotique
une terre d'accueil
j'imagine que tu as plein plein
propositions j'en ai eu j'ai été parfois
bien conseillés parfois un peu moins
bien j'ai eu un gros regret c'est quand
angela lorente il m'avait proposé de
présenter l'île de la tentation en fait
ouais et gérard louvin on avait un petit
peu interdit de le faire en fait
d'accord et c'est le plus gros regret
que j'ai eus parce que depuis là je
pense que j'aurais pu continuer une
vraie carrière d'animateur et les
mauvaises décisions qu'on a tous
présents les mauvaises décisions c'est
courir ces tissus sur bois c'est de me
lancer dans la musique alors que j'étais
pas fait pour ça c'était plus un kiff
qu'autre chose en fait c'était plus un
délire qu'autre chose c'est quoi ta vie
aujourd'hui tu vis ou et c'est quoi ta
vie je vais la réunion depuis trois ans
et demi avec mes enfants mais pourquoi
la réunion parce que on est là vivait
là-bas aux partisans de quitter la
france elle voulait aller la main des
pires au monde parce qu'elle avait son
frère qui vivaient là bah ouais et elle
voulait aller au soleil j'ai fait allez
on y va et puis voilà on est la bonne de
quoi là bas pour être je fais de
l'événementiel en ce moment un peu moins
mais j'ai fait beaucoup d'événements
sierre j'ai tenu des restes